the movie begins in the year 2022
depicting the cumulative effects of
overpopulation global warming and
pollution that have caused ecos side the
population has grown to 40 million
people in New York City alone as a
result most housing is dilapidated and
overcrowded the homeless fill the
streets stairways of buildings abandoned
cars Subway platforms and so on the
unemployment rate is skyrocketed
exceeding 50% only the elite can afford
spacious Apartments clean water and
quality food moreover their homes are
fortified with security systems and
personal bodyguards the majority of the
poor haul water from communal spigots
and eat highly processed food Wafers
produced by a single large food
processing firm called the soilent
corporation their Mainstay products
called soent red and soilent yellow are
marketed as high energy vegetable
concentrates the company has recently
launched their new product soilent green
which they claim can be a more
nutritious and flavorful wafer derived
from Plankton this will appease
SpongeBob however like most other Foods
its short supply will probably lead to
weekly food riots we are then introduced
to a New York City Police Department
detective Robert Thorne who lives in a
cramped one-bedroom apartment with his
aged friend Soul Roth soul is a former
college professor whose current job is
to sort through the now disordered
remnants of written records to help with
Robert's investigations he often
recounts the before the ecological
disaster and population crisis of the
early 2000s when real food was plentiful
however Robert doesn't seem to be
interested in these stories finding most
of them too hard to believe the
detective then leaves for his night
shift job but not before having to
tiptoe over people sleeping on the
stairs the following morning a guy named
Gilbert who is living in an abandoned
car is approached by A well-dressed man
named Donovan who hands him a meat hook
for an assassination mission turns out
that his Target is a wealthy lawyer
William Simonson who shares his lavish
apartment with his mistress Sherl the
Mistresses are referred to as Furniture
who have no human rights and are passed
from one apartment owner to the next
later that evening Cheryl and Williams
bodyguard tab goes to buy some food from
a vendor named Brady although the food
quantity is visibly less it costs over
$279 in the meantime Gilbert uses the
meat hook to sneak into William's
Mansion as he makes his way inside
William doesn't appear shocked to see
him as if he was expecting him ah the
meat hook man come come put it my bum he
then turns around allowing Gilbert to
strike him with a fatal Blow from behind
in the aftermath Robert is called for
the investigation of the case he
initiates his inquiry by talking to the
building superintendent Charles who
informs him that the security system
malfunctioned for the first time in 2
years Robert is then led to Williams
apartment where he meets Cheryl and tab
but instead of conducting a thorough
investigation the poorly paid detective
helps himself to the wealthy man's Food
liquor and some books not long after the
sanitation crew led by Vagner arrives to
take William's dead body away Robert
also leaves the place after stealing
some stuff from the apartment back in
his room he surpris his soul with
various stolen items including real
paper pencils a sizable bar of soap and
two volumes of the soilent oceanographic
survey report he further astounds him
with a bottle of alcohol and a piece of
beef which makes soul emotional sometime
later Robert heads to work where he sees
hundreds of people lining up to collect
death benefit money from recently
deceased friends and family members he
goes straight to his Superior officer
Lieutenant Hatcher's cabin in order to
report about William's case he believes
that Williams homicide is an
assassination rather than a burglary
since nothing was stolen from the
apartment and the murder seemed
professional he points out more evidence
to support his claim inoperative
security systems and the absence of
Williams bodyguard at the same same time
the next day Robert who is suspicious
towards tab Stakes out his apartment
building until he spots him leaving
following this he proceeds inside where
he meets tab's livein Furniture Martha
he asks her some questions while briefly
investigating the place but finds
nothing suspicious before departing he
secretly takes a spoon with remnants of
strawberry cake meanwhile soul is seen
in a queue waiting to collect water from
allocated Taps later in the evening
Robert is back at his apartment with
soul and the two enjoy a delicious food
stolen from William's place after dinner
Soul shares everything he uncovered
regarding William including the fact
that he was a board member of the
soilent corporation before leaving for
work Robert gives him the stolen spoon
asking him to taste it the old man can't
believe that he is actually savoring
strawberries that cost $150 a jar oh
they're delicious following this Robert
revisits William's apartment to question
Sheryl who is currently having some
drinks with her fellow Furniture
companions he takes her to the bedroom
to talk to her in private and inquires
about Williams friends family and
relatives in response Cheryl mentions a
few names and one of them includes New
York State's Governor Henry Santini she
further discloses that William seemed
deeply troubled in the days before his
death and that he even took her to a
local Catholic Church the conversation
then takes an unexpected turn and the
two end up making out in the bed must
have been that mention of the Pope in
the midst of their intimacy Charles
enters the apartment and begins yelling
at the girls for slacking off he even
gets abusive and hits a couple of girls
until Robert intervenes he asks about
the matter to which the superintendent
response that the girls are
disrespecting the building policy in
order to protect them the detective
claims that he called them for
questioning he also warns Charles
against assaulting the girls from now on
threatening legal action after sending
Charles and the rest of the furniture
girls away Robert also prepares to get
going himself however Sheryl who does
not want to be alone tries to convince
him to stay for a little longer offering
him a hot shower and a lovely breakfast
the poor detective is unable to refuse
such luxury prompting him to stay after
this the two spend some romantic time in
the shower and enjoy a great meal before
departing The Perks of Being a detective
in this world are off the goddamn chain
early the next morning Robert visits the
local Catholic Church mentioned by Sherl
which is filled with hundreds of
homeless people there he approaches the
priest and questions him about William's
confession however the priest is VIs
visibly exhausted overwhelmed by the
plight of all the homeless people he
remembers talking to William but cannot
recall the specifics as a result he only
leaves a hint claiming that the truth is
too hard to Bear the very next day tab
goes to the church and murders the
priest in the confessional Booth
ensuring that he never talks again as
Robert continues delving into the murder
case Governor Santini instructs his
chief of security who is none other than
Donovan to close the investigation it
turns out that Santini was once with
Williams partner in a high-profile law
firm and is The Mastermind behind all of
this following his instruction Donovan
relays the information to Lieutenant
Hatcher which the latter agrees with
later that day Robert walks into
Hatcher's office to report further
details and leads on the murder case but
to his surprise the lieutenant declares
that Williams case is officially closed
sensing something a Miss Robert refuses
to do so and instead accuses Hatcher of
bribery when Governor Santini learns of
this he orders Donovan to have the
detective murdered the scene then cuts
to the day of soilent green rations
distribution and several police officers
including Robert are assigned to guard
the area in case of a riot as
anticipated chaos erupts and authorities
struggle to control the violent throng
soon after several large dump trucks
called Scoops designed by the NYC Riot
police arrive on the scene in order to
pick up closely packed riers scooping
them in in the midst of this Mayhem the
local assassin For Hire Gilbert ber
appears and tries to shoot Robert he
fires several shots towards the
detective with his silenced pistol but
misses his Target and instead kills
several innocent bystanders Gilbert's
work in pro bono for sure seeing this
Robert chases the asent into the dense
crowd and eventually manages to catch
him he then throws him to the ground but
Gilbert rolls over and shoots him in his
right leg before the detective can
retaliate the asent is crushed by the
hydraulic shovel of one of the police
riot control vehicles Gilbert ber got
scooped later Robert confronts tab at
his residence and beats him up demanding
to reveal the Mastermind behind all of
this however tab opts not to utter a
single word amidst the commotion Martha
tries to intervene but Robert pushes her
away he then issues a Stern warning to
stay clear from his investigation before
leaving following this the detective
goes to William's apartment and finds
comfort in Cheryl's arms she assists in
tending to his wound cleaning it and
applying a bandage as they Converse
Cheryl tells him that a new tenant will
be arriving at the apartment since she
has developed romantic feelings for
Robert she has a thought of moving out
of the place but she is not sure about
it after resting for about an hour he
leaves the apartment as sirens for the
nightly curfew begin sounding on the
other hand Soul carries the soilent
oceanographic survey report and goes to
the Supreme exchange a library where
former professors and judges work with
the help of these people Soul concludes
that the oceans are deteriorating and
are incapable of producing the Plankton
supposedly used in soilent green he
further unveils a horrible Revelation
the ingredients in soilent green are in
fact human bodies this information
confirms to Soul that Williams murder
was orchestrated by his fellow soilent
Corporation board members who feared
that he might expose this unsettling
truth to the public soul is so shaken by
the truth that he opts for assisted
suicide at a government Clinic it
appears that the government has
established a clinic for voluntary Mass
euthanasia due to overcrowding a process
referred to as good going home in the
meantime Robert arrives back home and
finds a goodbye note from Saul as a
result he frantically rushes to the
clinic to stop him but arrives too late
as the process has already begun in his
final moments Saul watches video clips
showcasing a thriving Earth devoid of
pollution Robert also watches this from
outside the room which breaks him down
into tears before dying the old man
Whispers his Discovery to Robert which
leaves him in shock you're eating people
Bob anyway see you he also tells them
that they need proof of what is
happening before they can approach the
Council of Nations but I'm tapping out
so that's on you buddy Robert then
sneaks into the basement of the assisted
suicide facility where he sees corpses
being loaded onto waste disposal tracks
he discreetly hitches a ride on one of
them which then transports him to a
heavily guarded waste disposal plant
just outside the city once inside he is
appalled to witness how the corpses are
processed into soilent green Wafers not
long after Robert is spotted by some
plant workers and it's chased he manages
to subdue two of them and fleas the
scene just before the alarm goes off in
the aftermath Robert races to the
Supreme exchange to report his findings
but is ambushed by the soilent operative
Tab and his man in a swift move Robert
gets to a pay phone and calls Hatcher
who is preoccupied at the moment he then
makes a call to shurl and confesses his
love for her however he instructs her to
stay with her new tenant for safety
reasons moments later he gets connected
to the lieutenant and alerts him about
the current situation along with his
whereabouts just then the armed asants
locate him and start chasing him through
the deserted streets and alleys they
also open fire towards him and they're
better at it than Gilbert and one of the
bullets hits him causing a serious
injury to his waist despite this Robert
manages to make his way inside the
church and hides among the homeless
people as tab enters Robert attacks him
from behind initiating a physical brawl
between the two however the weakened
Robert is beaten up and knocked down to
the ground fortunately he finds a rusted
kitchen knife which he then uses to stab
the asant to death turning him into food
after a while the police along with the
paramedics arrive on the scene and
prepare to load Robert into the
ambulance before being taken away he
confides the Horrible Secret to Hatcher
urging him to spread this news to the
entire nation the movie ends as Robert
shouts out to the surrounding crowd
soent green is people subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching